اذا اتهاماتهم متبادله بالمسؤوليه عن
كارثه مائيه وبيئيه كبرى هي الاولى بهذا
الحجم منذ بدء حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
كارثه قد لا تقتصر تاثيراتها على غرق
عشرات المناطق السكانيه في اوكرانيا بل
ربما يصل تاثيرها الى مستويات ابعد في
البحر الاسود تتهم كييف موسكو بتفجير السد
من داخله من هنا بينما تقول روسيا ان
القصف الاوكراني على السد خلال المعارك
المعارك خيرسون طبعا والمعارك الجاريه
انتهى الى دماره اليوم 16 الف شخص يعيشون
في المنطقه الحرجه التي نراها هنا المهدده
بالفيضانات بحسب مسؤول اوكرانيا البلدات
المعرضه للغرق نتحدث عن نحو 80 بلده ايضا
نتحدث هنا عن اجزاء من خرسون وعشره قرى
كما تلاحظون اللون الغامق هذا الذي هنا هو
لون مجرى النهر الاصلي اللون الفاتح هذا
اللون الازرق هو لون الفيضانات التي بدات
حقيقه خرائط جوجل فعليا باظهار تحذيرات
منها نراها هنا في اوليف كافي
انتونيف كاخيرسون ووصولا اخيرا الى
بيلوزيركا هناك اثار اخرى لانهيار السد
فضلا عن ازمه الطاقه التي ستحدث بسبب تعطل
محطه
نوفاكا خوفاكا للطاقه الكهربائيه فضلا عن
هذه الازمه التي تحصل هنا هناك ايضا مخاوف
جديه بالنسبه لمحطه زبروج النوويه هذه
المحطه التي نراها هنا اوضحها اكثر لكم
على الخريطه هذه المحطه تعتمد اكبر محطه
نوويه في اوروبا وبدانا نسمع هذه المخاوف
لتصريحات لعدد من المسؤولين حيث تعتمد كما
ذكرنا على مياه
هنا في عمليات التبريد لكن وكاله الطاقه
الدوليه للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
تؤكد ان المحطه حتى الان بامان وليس ضمن
نطاق التهديد بينما دمرت المحطه
الكهربائيه هنا بشكل كامل جزء مهم من دور
السد الن خزان وهذا الخزان المائي هنا
يوفر المياه لقناه القرم المائيه هذه
القناه التي نلاحظها هنا دعونا نتذكر قصه
هذه القناه بعد ضم روسيا للقرن عام 2014
هذه المنطقه شبه جزيره القرم قطعت
اوكرانيا هذه القناه المائيه التي نراها
هنا قطعت المياه عنها ما ادى الى شحمه
ومشاكل زراعيه كبرى في القرن لسنوات عده
مع بدايه حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا كان
اعاده فتح هذه القناه اول ما قامت به
روسيا بعد ان سيطرت على هذه المناطق وهنا
طبعا من المعروف انه خلال معارك السيطره
على خي تعرض السد هنا لعدد من الانفجارات
نظرا لانه ايضا طريق امداد عسكري بين ضفتي
النهر الان هذه الصوره
التقطت من الفضاء بدايه شهر مايو الماضي
تظهر ان روسيا ورغم كل ما تعرض له السد من
انفجارات وضعضع بسبب الحرب اغلقت بواباته
لحجز كميه اكبر من المياه الى ان شاهد هذا
المنظر الفضائي وهو كما ترون هنا وضح لكم
المنطقه هذه المنطقه
نرى تدفق المياه فيها من اعلى السد ما
يعني ان الخزان المائي وصل امتلا الى اعلى
حدوده ومن هنا اتهم مسؤولون اوكرانيون
روسيا بانها ربما حملت سد المضعضع فوق
طاقته كما تلاحظون نتحدث هنا عن سد يبلغ
ارتفاعه تقريبا حوالي 30
مترا بطول طول السد كامل تقريبا يتجاوز
ثلاثه الاف متر وبالتالي هو يحجز خلف وهنا
اكثر من ثمانيه عشر مليار متر مكعب من
المياه في خزانه الماء الكبير والذي من
المتوقع ان يفرغ الكثير منه
متسببا في فيضانات ضخمه خلال الساعات
الحاليه والقادمه